well good evening i'd like to ask
what was your based on to create such
strong characters
such as for example cersei or caitlyn
in a world where women wouldn't
almost have any power or any sort of
ways to show themselves basically
what was you based on to create such
characters in the books
uh i think that he asked about um about
the women
and the the way that they were portrayed
in those worlds that
they didn't have any power so where did
you get the
inspiration to get so powerful with
those characters of the women's the
women well i
you know i drew much of my inspiration
from history
um if you read a lot of medieval history
uh like westeros it's uh basically a
patriarchal society where women
um have quite restricted
uh roles in society and there are
certain things that women are not
allowed to do
uh you know i mean they're not allowed
to to be the pope or to be a bishop
or to have offices in the church um
depending on a country they in some
cases they could inherit a crown or or a
lordship in other cases they could not
that changed over time in various things
they were not allowed to enter certain
professions they were you know the
property of their husband or their
father
or whatever all of these restrictions
existed and women had to
function under them for many centuries
nonetheless
various strong and powerful women still
arose
and affected the course of of history
eleanor of aquitaine was the wife of two
kings
and mother to two more kings
and was probably the one of the most
dominant personalities of her age
joan of arc turned the entire course of
the
100 years war and created uh
france as it exists today as rather than
being just part of uh
england uh these these two characters
are
very well known but there are there were
many others isabella of spain
um you know partner with uh ferdinand a
hugely powerful queen
elizabeth the first of england even her
her mother
mary tudor or her sister rather mary
tudor
um going back centuries earlier
the civil war in england between stephen
and matilda which was over
whether in fact a woman could in fact
inherit the english crown
and they passed her over but she was
pissed about it and went to war and
you know that war ripped england apart
for a generation
um so there have been many strong women
in history even though
um the society was by no means an
egalitarian one
and i try to reflect both things in my
books to
to show a society that doesn't give
women equal rights and
the frustrations and the pain and the
difficulties that cause many of the
women but
also to show certain women of strong
character or ability
um dealing with that in one way or
another and what kind of accommodations
they
they make with that and how they succeed
despite these restrictions and
the cost because there's always a kind
of a cost when you
buck your social expectations um
but it's certainly one of the things
that uh
that i deal with in uh in the books one
of the things that pleases me both about
these books is that i do have
so many uh women readers and that so
many of them come up to me and tell me
they
they do like the uh the women characters
in the books
um because that is something i work on
and um
it's not true of a lot of fantasy i
think a lot of fantasy
either
neglects women or if they do use women
like the women warrior has become sort
of a stock almost cartoonish character
the
the babe in the brass bikini uh which is
sort of impractical um so i'm
trying to uh trying to deal with these
things and turn these on their head and
offer
a wide variety of different women who
are different from each other
and reflect different ways of dealing
with a kind of society like that